explosion trafic aérien les troupes
population y militer et senna du kosovo
consoeur un avertissement de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé le
virus zika pourrait se propager à tous
les pays des amériques où l'on retrouve
le moustique qui le transmet ce virus
serait responsable chez les nouveau nés
au brésil de près de 4000 qu'un de
microcéphalie qui est une croissance
inférieure est anormal du cerveau au
total plus d'un million brésilien aurait
été infecté par le virus zika mais le
risque pour les canadiens est faible
puisque le virus est transmis par un
moustique qui n'est pas présent au pays
on sort michèle alfort c'est de l'art
évidemment quand tu es un nouveau virus
on peut craindre une pandémie qu en est
il exactement
bon ce sera d'abord et avant tout les
pays où vous voulez vider les moustiques
est présent mais c'est une maladie qui
n'est pas mortelle dans un premier temps
et qui pour l'instant n'a pas preuve qui
se transmet de personne en personne
alors déjà c'est ça de gagné donc il est
apparu en ouganda 1947 d'abord il
infecte et l'afrique ensuite dans les
hits du sud est et des gens justement de
ces deux pays là en 2014 aurait transmis
cette maladie là lors du mondial du
football au brésil
et depuis on a cette éclosion massive
d'une fièvre alors regardons les
symptômes de ça on appelle ça la fièvre
zika à l'eau si on regarde de bon le
moustique à des cegid si c'est le sait
le moyen par lequel le virus se transmet
et l'a d'abord il faut le dire il n'ya
qu'une personne sur cinq là qui
développe les symptômes c'est pas tout
le monde
des éruptions cutanées une forme
d'arthrite de la fièvre conjonctivite
autour des yeux est bon une semaine
maximum et après ça on est guéri mais la
complication c'est microcéphalie
possible c'est pour ça qu'on en parle ce
soit ça c'est ce qui inquiète les
autorités sanitaires microcéphalie donc
c'est un crâne un peu plus de dix
cerveaux plus bullish aider
on n'avait jamais vu ça avec un virus il
y avait à peu près 200 personnes bon an
mal an briser le kavé salon est à 4000
l'hypothèse c'est que possiblement ce
virus-là se rendraient lors du premier
tiers de la gestation de la mer
attaquerait le foetus et réduire la
taille mais on n'a qu'une seule étude
pour l'instant on voit le corrélation
entre les deux mais on n'a pas de
preuves on dit aux femmes de ne pas se
rendre dans ces pays là si elles sont
enceintes de passer un test mais là le
test
vu que les symptômes ne sont pas
toujours présents le test qui est très
peu efficace d'ailleurs est ce que c'est
la solution pas pour l'instant
alors on a on a un portrait pour la
femme qui est inquiétant mais n'ont pas
encore les preuves définitives alors
vous allez parler des pays qui sont
touchés
parlons-en de la progression de ce virus
est ce qui pourrait éventuellement
atteindre le canada bien coûter en un an
et demi c'est quand même assez fascinant
il n'y avait pas du minutes d'immunité
chez les gens d'amérique du sud
regardons la carte ensemble ça l'a
effectivement a fait une flambée
regarder tous les pays en rouge là en
moins d'un an ce qui inquiète et surtout
pour nos touristes canadiens le mexique
que les caraïbes et il va probablement
monter puisque ce moustique là est
présent dans le sud des états unis à
savoir s'il va se rendre jusqu'au québec
l'été prochain pour l'instant on n'a pas
ce moustique là est ce que le virus va
changer de moustiques ça on ne sait pas
encore bon alors des conseils pour les
voyageurs canadiens avaient parlé du
fameux dans cette même pas juste les
femmes dans sa tombe bien nous venons si
on ne veut pas voir cette fièvre là
alors c'est un virus deux jours
contrairement à l'âme à la malaria qui
est un virus de nuit donc le jour donc
faut se couvrir les bras les jambes mais
des anti moustique est tentée d'être à
l'air climatisé le plus possible ne pas
aller dans si willy là vous serez danse
donc pour les voyageurs
oui donc prudence pour les voyageurs on
va suivre ça céline ensemble ça risque
d'évoluer jusqu'à jusqu'au printemps
jusqu'à l'été merci beaucoup moins cher
c'est beaucoup ce début